やすお願いいたします明日からない
えっと今日は和歌山で頭とか行ってきました
そりゃの私最初にこの出番があるのかな
っていう感じでまあなどこんな鳥任されてできる子可愛いなと言われたかと思ったん
です
塾びっくりしましたお腹その中で今日はお話しさせていただきたいと思いますので
よろしくお願い致します
はいということで今日お話しさせていただくのは8年目の sns との付き合い方と
いうことでへ洗練性について話していきたいとおもいます
まあなんか私のツイッターとかプローしていくんだって語ってちなみこんなが何人
くらいいらっしゃいますか
やられていただけ
思ったりいないでよかった人と私がついたら出す事バレちゃうんでまぁもし良かった後
で見てみてください
あり肌結構 twitter 目に使ってソロわぁが今には3000人くらいですかね
まぁなんか掃除機塞さんはじめた時は300人くらいバースタートしたのでまぁ3年
って言ったら変なした女優大きい人数はこうやって見てるわけですか
横浜レナトから大声で潰れてるようなもんで
お腹減ったってこんなをニーズ塗っていいのか来ないと思っ
はいということで今回は sns の流れをいったんこざっと確認できたらいいかなと
思ったので
最初の最初から離していきたいなと思います私が最初にこう携帯とか
愛花
何ですかねパソコン以外ので刃石に触れたのが初めてなのかおそらくガラケー
まあこの中でも持ってた方って多いと思うんですけどちょうど私が中学1年生の頃
なので大体煌8年前くらいですね今から8年9年前くらいには
私は彼ら計を気にしました
まあ相当者とデコメールみたいなものなどに動くフレームだってとか4文字みたいな
ものを使ってた方も多いんじゃないかなと思い
りそこで始まったのがボタン学校皆さんがカラー剣持ち始めることでネットにすぐに
つなげるようになってパソコン以外にも肥え先日みたいなものがダンカン発達してき
ました
そこで一番最初に出てきたのか牡馬下モバゲーとかすごい懐かしいいる計算私は24
年間ずっとやってましたけど
まあなんかモバゲーみたいなので例えば or
パターだったりとかゲームだったりとかあと箱をサークル数という掲示板みたいなもん
だったりとか
あとちょうどこうネット創設まあなんかケータイ小説星戦闘でて言うとそういったもの
が出始めたのもちょうどモバゲーとかが多いですね
未だに好きな高小説家の方とかでもが現発で書いてらっしゃる方とかもいます
まぁそこでここで一番大きなポイントが
地位に未知との遭遇がここで初めて行われたわけですね
私とかま学生だった時は思えたりしてほしいんですけど基本的には後学内の友達だっ
たりとか
まあもともと小学校の同級生とか幼馴染っていうコミュニティがだけ
なかなか来る学生という立場で人と関わる機会てなかったと思うんですよね
まあ今でもそこフェイスブックとかいろんな誰かとつながりますけど当時で言ったら
たまたの修学旅行先でマッチングした学校のことを
分つを怪我3ひたすら書いてあるとかあと雑誌見てこう
て紙を封筒にトレック最初感とかまれながら書いたりっていうのも懐かしい方もいるん
じゃないかな
ありましたがまあ中そこから常にその枚書いた世界いわゆるその
北海道だったりとか例えば沖縄の方だったりとかの人とふらんじゃ絶対合わないよね
育ちと出会う未知との遭遇が sns が始まることによってできるようになりました
私自身も学校だったりところ結構いじめられてたこともあったんで
けどそれたところから一歩抜けて色々な人に出会える機会が出来たってのはすごい
良かったなと思う
電話メールが艦隊のも曲ありましたよね今はカルトだと分かってもらえないんですけど
懸命なとに
リーフィーみたいなぜてきたこともすごいありますよね
まあ皆さんを好きな女の子とかにメールするときとかに気がいっぱいつながってからば
嬉しいみたいな思い出がある方もいるんじゃないかなと思います
あの j 文化みたいなものもあってまあ基本的某 sns でのオフ会みたいなもの
をこの時期に始まったのかなと私は思っています
そしてここからさらに数年が経ちましてまた得て1年くらいですかでビッグ c って
いうものがやってきますここらへんからだんだんと一般の方にも広がってきたのかな
ものですが
まあ mixi っていうことが何が特別だったかっていうと
今日げーまーじゃん陸士当てた方ってどれくらいいますか
あの思って少ないし半分かですかねまあ mixi 始めた時のことを思い出して
ほしいんですけど今じゃありえないですけど基本的あるって招待してましたですよね
最初の
友だちからの招待メールほら単語じゃないとそれにエントリーできないっていうか自分
のアカウント作れなかったんですよ
なんで基本的にはこう友達ず背に紹介してもらったはいるって言う間
いわゆるそのリアルと付ラインが混じった感じ
まりあるとこうやとオンラインでアートオンラインの混じった感じの
なのでこう生活の延長上みたいな感じが強かったのかなと思います
あなたがそういったことがあったので私と彼が一番酸っぱいさなと思ったのが
もうめちゃくちゃ好きなバンドのことですら行って友達に学校ですよ
this write すんバーが経ってその後日系書いたんすよ mixi の日記
に
そしたらその5分前によ天の下友達のことを友達 c して受けてたんですよ
まあ6実結果になってその後の中なかなかのできなかったですけどそういった失敗も
結構あるんじゃないかなと思います
まあなのでこの当時で言えばでも言ってもシリア入ってるのコミュニティてるかと地雷
邪魔するという感じで sns
としてもちょっと特殊だったじゃないかなと思います
エマーソン中で同じ暗さのいわゆるを服が好きな人とか音楽が好きな人って
コミュニティも結構発達してきました
今ここでネットでの場合はみたいなものもだんだん増えてきたかなと思います
ダン抱っこアメーバとかなぁ micro みたいなものがあってネット犯罪みたいな
ものもやはりユーザーが増えてくるとだんだんと出てきました
で私はだいたい高校生に入った頃なんで今から5年愛とかですかねそのこのくらいから
5段スマホを持つ方も増えてきました
私はカットスマホ持つのが遅かったらので twitter とかをなど小腹径の
小さい画面でやってたりしたんですけどだんだんスマホが一般化することによって
つ一回の交流 new をどんどん
行ってきました未だにもツイッターやってる方って結構この中でいっぱいやすると思う
んですけど
まあかなりこれになると
左感想というか今までネットとかちょっと怖かったけど行ってみようみたいな方も
すごいと思います
いっぱいなぁとこう
どんどん体重の人が参加してくるといわゆるをてるみたいな状態
当てるとかとこう有名人として1人2人とか3人とかもいっぱいいるじゃないですか
それかた後商品汗まあ紹介し淡水のバカ売れするみたいないわゆるピンフレーサーと
いうものもここら辺ですごい増えてきたかなと思います
なので[ __ ]断端使用者が行為ままじゃ流れを見てきたはからと思うんですけど
だんだんだんだん使用者が増えてきてだんだんと皆さんと聞いてても知ってる名前は
増えてきたんじゃないかなと思います
せたかねこうしろ人数が増えるごとにだんだん内にある英の拡張となってきていますね
まあそしてさらにこういう家をかけたのフェイスブックが一般化したことですね
正直私もびっくりしてるんですけど私のお父さんとかすごくは2000 s 弱いん
ですよ
でも型ザクかけたらなぜか父親がやっていてしかもなぜか
父親の名前苗字の方を間違ったの登録しているのがすごい謎なんですよ
井筒思うかな
てるんですけどまぁとりあえずそのまま放置されますしかマイコンがで今させてって
いう
まあだかそんな彼にこのおじいさんにフェイスブックやっていうこととか見ると思うん
ですけど
村介護一般化しています
一緒にコーラインラインで実はこう
東北の大川さんの妻できたものなので結構最近のものなんですよね
まあ今考えるとこう年くらいずっと使ってた気がするとか思うんですけど案外高校3年
とか米とかそういったことだと思う
でそこからですねこう twitter facebook line って出てきた
ところでかなりこの時点です
出会いが様々になってきたかなと思います正直そののば下とか
mixi とかの時代ってそこで人とことってすごいタブー視されてたと思うんですよ
浦上たらそんな危ないよくじゃないすばっちゃいけないよとか本当にそれでは実際判断
もちょっとずつあったーーー
とはいえばその時よりも今のほうが多いとこう人とワークぞとか
まぁ今回のその主催の方のかも実は私ネットがあっあのが最初きっかけだったりするん
ですよ
まあそうか以降出会いの形でいろいろ
浸透してきたのかなと思います
まあ実はですねすごく前的な話になったんですけど私の彼氏だったりとか
私の友人だったりとかうちのスタッフって基本的にツイッターで出るんでしょうか多い
んですよね
雨これ言いたくないんですけど私もとかでも今の会社も出会いはなんです勝っていき
たいと
ちったぁです手元にします何旅行将来ご結婚式の帰るときとかに
二人の馴れ初めは twitter s 出るとかすんごいやで今に行動に角を隠せ
ないかなって考えてるんですけど本当にまあそれくらい子
出会いってまあフラットになってきてるのかなと思います
それこそ家のデザイナーさんとかも
たまたまリツイートで今流れてきた服はすんごいかわいいものでそれがどうか祭で展示
されているって聞いてもう今から会いに行くんで1時間後でしょこれ待っててくださ
いってまぁ男の人が入ったらなんですけど私がそういうことをやって実際スカートしっ
に会社に入ってもらってます今年中に再投与する予定
それくらいの人がこうツイッターでの出会いで私あてられたんですよね
まあそれから来出会いがある一方でマラ廃村リテラシー
ネットリテラシーが低い人もで参加できるようになっていうのもやはり弊害がありまし
て
ima はソネットとか向こうにこう画面越しに人がいるとも知らずに
意味わかんないことを言ってくる人とかもやはり正直増えてきたかなと思います
今
結局ネットリテラシーって何なのかっていう話を
まあ最後も分でさせていただきたいなと思うのですが組織私はネットリテラシーという
ものはネット先に誰かしら人がいて
まあそれにその自分が滑ったことだったりとか自分が発信したことってものが a に
上るっていうことを自覚していることであるのか
なと私は思っていますなので例えばですねこう
ネットにバンバン彼氏との写真とか彼女とちょっとかあげる人とかいるじゃないですか
そういったものを別れたあとに新しいか塗るとか見られたところでそれは文句言えない
わけですよこちら公開していてそ旅行世の中の全員に見せれる権利を取っちゃ選んで
いるわけですからね
なんかそういったことが好ネットリテラシーなのかなとはた車
思っています
まあ入ってしまいますね先天性のイメージをそのまま異性年生になるっていうのも
楽しいかなと思っていて例えばスネ生ネスでいろいろなものを見せてる人嫌だって言っ
て限って案外そうの自分も交換が遠くに人がいると感じ
ご覧そういうことをやる人とかも多いかなと思う
はい
sms になってますよね sns はフォームフォームを倍増できることですね
やっぱりその結構空いてんですが発達してきたことに twitter とか
facebook でシェアさあ報告したらこういい音がいっぱい付いたりとか
いろいろコメント巻いてるとか幸せなことはいっぱいあると思うんですけど
はいその1本マイナスな事言ったらそのまま帰ってきてしまう
のも正直なところですキャンて蛍光 sns っていうものは人がどーっ通してくれて
まあそれ高を倍増するものだということを自覚してあまりこ否定的な事を書かないだっ
たりとかそういったことを自分の中でルーズ消していくことでうまく使えるのかなと
まあなので私は強敵に sns でマイナスなことでて儚いだったりとか
匿名の寿命をあげないとかそういったものをすぐ心がけています
やはりその sns での発言一つ一つが自分の体にこう活動へツイートを突くような
ものだと考えるのが一番それせいですとの付き合い方としていいのかなと私は今から
伝えした立ったところはここですね結構その sns で
私が意識しているところは自分のつぶやきをプリントアウトしてそれを体に貼って
歩けるかっていうのを所が考えていて結構そのハッピー歩けちゃうようなことを
つぶやいている方って多いじゃないですか
例えばその桐谷こういうことが足に行ったりとか
小旅行いうことがあってすごい嫌だったとか面白い貼ってあるけれどどこ素顔
んですけどあなんかそれからこう人に見られているものだっていう自覚をしていくこと
まあそれだけ洸一
いろんな人に私の場合だったらま23002きっとそれ以上の人がいるのはたさん
ツイッター見てくださってるんですよね
あなんかそういったことすごくを常に意識して渋谷のホースクランプコスてんだったり
とか分からんだったら分かる
駅前とかで自分のつぶやきを持っても大丈夫かっていうのを意識していくといいかなと
思います
私は sns 生まれ sns 育っティ
ちょっと自己紹介が遅れたんですけど私自身がその sns を使って企業主体の
ハタチの大学生です
それでもともと自分の交代ずだったりとか服だったりとかを自分で作ってたんですけど
それがこう sns 発で色々な方に知っていただいて
ちょっと多分今年の秋くらいで自分のタスクが1万着を超えるんですよ
ああそれから多くの人に受け取っていただいているんですけどそれもこれも基本的に
渡し会青年冊
てやってるんですよねなんかそれだけ高大きなビジネスチャンス言ってみればまあ私の
ゲストターニングポイントであったものが sns だしー
焼津お仕事五回に関しても
まあ今の彼氏だったりとか友達だったりとか
内の色々相談できる友達だったりとかって結構その会青年誌つながりだった者せる
し合った方がすごい多いですだからこそ
すごい sns に感謝していますやっぱその
まぁ色々怖いせ犬だったりとかがテレビで流れてすごい嫌なイメージを持っている方も
多いとは思うんですけど私はすごい千年生に感謝してるし正直
sns がなかった今ここに登壇することもないと思うんですよ
だからもそうまあここにいる皆さんにも今後高 sns です失敗することだったりと
か
何かそのするようなことはしてほしくないなーということで今日のお話をさせて
いただけました
つまるところですねやはり染め西寧さあ
1ツールやって居場所にもなってくれるって言うのは確かなんですけどツールだって
こうしてるになるもの
様々なところに発信されて今後残っていくもの
きゅーのまぁ良くも悪くもすごい化していけたら楽しい氷製ですレントが増えるんじゃ
ないかなと私は思います
ということで今日のお話ありがとうございました早川組でした